le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
tous les cirques se sont construits
grâce à elle elle nous fait vivre
mafate et dessiné par ces sillage la
ressource en eau est surveillé au
quotidien par julia et ses équipes
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour vous fait quoi là mais
on travaille à l'office de l'eau réunion
on aime bien faire des mesures dans la
rivière j'peux allons voir ça allait je
suis le petit crapaud
je m'appelle julien monnier je travaille
à l'office de l'eau réunion et je suis
au sein de la direction du développement
durable des territoires
les coureurs c'est pas encore demain non
c'est bien connu sont sur la rivière des
galets qui est une rivière majeur à la
réunion qui draine tout le cirque de
mafate et c'est une rivière qui a une
qualité de l'eau plutôt bonne avec pas
trop de pollution détectée
lorsqu'à dollar vers quoi ils sont à la
base de la chaîne alimentaire est la
suivante quand je vois une rivière je
vois tout un écosystème riche et divers
et qui interagit entre les poissons les
invertébrés et toutes les paroles les
larves d'insectes qu'on trouve sous les
roches ou bien sur les berges qui vont
venir nourrir les poissons et donc c'est
tout ce cycle que l'on voit nous se
développer sous nos yeux quand on
s'approche d'une rivière
moi ce que j'aime dans ce métier c'est
que déjà j'aime la nature depuis
toujours et l'eau en fait fait ce
contact fort entre l'homme et la nature
et donc nous on a besoin pour une
gestion durable est un développement
harmonieux de nos activités de connaître
cette nature est d'arriver à bien la
gérer pour être en équilibre avec elle
même ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même de
la vie ouvrages qui sont sur cette
rivière qui prélève de l'eau est
également des pêcheries qui se trouve à
l'embouchure
donc dans l'ensemble on a quand même des
activités humaines qui viennent avoir
des impacts sur cette vie et cette
biodiversité réunionnaise
[Musique]
alors tu vas pour donner une idée on a
plus de 7 milliards de mètres cubes par
an qui vient de la pluie à la réunion 7
milliards 7 milliards c'est à dire la
crau chanteur il ya à peu près un
milliard qui passent dans nos rivières
ça et nous nous la ce qu'on consomme
c'est à peu près 200 millions de mètres
cubes par an donc c'est rien par rapport
à tout ce qui nous arrive donc on voit
bien que à la réunion on n'a pas de
problème de quantité d'eau on a plutôt
un problème de répartition et de gestion
et de partage donc nous l'office de
l'eau on s'intéresse à la ressource en
eau sur l'ensemble de l'île
effectivement donc on a plusieurs
dizaines de stations de mesure à la fois
dans les rivières pour connaître leur
débit est également leur qualité mais
également pour les eaux souterraines
toutes les nappes phréatiques qu'on a
sous les pieds est également s'intéresse
à au milieu marin et notamment les
corons sur lesquels on réalise des
suivis pour voir un petit peu leur état
83 50
parce qu'on va défiler là c'est la
vitesse de l'eau allez c'est parti
mesure mesure l'eau en fait fait ce
contact fort entre l'homme et la nature
et donc nous on a besoin pour une
gestion durable est un développement
harmonieux
de nos activités de connaître cette
nature est d'arriver à bien la gérer
pour être en équilibre avec elle même on
a ce devoir nous de garder le cap et
d'informer ça soit la population ou bien
les gestionnaires des défis qu'on a à
relever pour qu on les relève tous
ensemble merci monsieur
franchement moi je voulais c'est la
rivière je continue direction la redoute
merci à bombannes cours merci votre
continuation aller à l'eau le
département vous a présenté terre de
trail